the start of this game will have been
delayed about two and a half hours
because of intermittent rain it might be
worth the wait though because cy young
award winners going up against each
other and they'll be going up against
that guy corey kluber in his seventh
start two and two his era all the way
down to 3.03
right back the kluber knocks it down
and gets the out
that hit him right in the glove and then
drop straight
[Music]
down swing and a miss harrison down on
strikes two away
and the one-two pitch
dribbled back to the mound
and a one-two-three inning for corey
kluber as he retires the nationals in
order here's a future hall of famer
maybe number 31 will never be worn by
anybody else in the district of columbia
ninth career start against new york he's
four and four with the 434 era
and it high in the air to right
soto barely moves now back in a couple
of steps to make the catch
and he was guessing and guessing wrong
so max ties mickey lolich
the great detroit tiger who won 217
games in his big league career with
strikeout number 2832
moving up the list and that was a slider
that didn't do a whole lot
see a little bit of that sliding action
but not the dramatic sweep to the max
shares or slider that you usually see
o2 to judge
oh max pulls out the change up early so
hello mickey lolich goodbye mickey
lowledge
he gets stanton and judge the yankees
two big guns down on strikes
and ryan zimmerman looks like that
should be an infield knock
on the backhand side for glebe torres
ryan up their first pit swinging
and the nats have a
lead off man aboard here top of the
second
and number 1800 for ryan zimmerman got
history all over the place today
one two to bell
swings had a pitch up in the zone
higashioka holds on to the tip
one away
and max is striking out everybody in
sight that's three in a row and you talk
about the meat of the order dan stanton
judge taurus
fastball up forget about it
four in a row for max in new york
that is perfect
lower left quadrant six in a row to
start the game five strikeouts in a row
and max strutting toward the third base
dugout
be very careful
this could be two hot hitters
come home they'll get one and a
beautiful scoop on the backhand by
higashiyoka
to keep his foot on hold plate and
record the out
3-1 count career wants soto 4 52 hit her
he'll take the walk and the nats are on
top
that's a 3-1 change-up wanted no part
of a fastball in the zone to one of the
most dangerous hitters in major league
baseball
and the nats are on the board as a
result
and the o2
grounded to short torres
gets zimmerman and that will do it
oh one away here is higashiyoka
fly ball deep left field schwarber back
he's on the track at the wall sia tiger
that's a big statement for iggy i mean
after you strike out numerous people in
a row all of a sudden cooper's got to be
thinking man i've already given up a run
this is an off speed pitch and he just
kind of hung it and all of a sudden
higgy puts him on the board
another change-up so max two more
strikeouts in the third he has seven on
the day
and the 2-2 pitch
strike three bell down looking
the o2
swing and a miss schwarber
down on strikes first and second two
outs clover deals
strike three
robles down looking a no contact inning
two walks three strikeouts
wow he made him look bad there that's
number eight for max scherzer
swang and a tip and a strikeout
number nine and that's three in a row oh
two target up
that's right where you want it
max scherzer 10ks in four innings
and it's the 100th time in his big
league career he has struck out 10 or
more
two two
that's a great slider that's the one he
wanted to throw back in the third inning
so max scherzer 11 k's
zimmerman bell schwarper ahead we've got
a classic going here in the bronx
schwarber a laser right field line
that's going to hop the wall it sits
right down off the advertising sign and
schwarber gets into second on a very
close play right now it's going to be a
kluber castro matchup
castro up the middle base hit schwarber
around third ball slowed down by the wet
outfield and the nats
will put a pair of two out hits together
to retake the lead and now castro leads
the ball club with 14 runs batted in
swang gonna miss
making a really good hitter look bad
number 12.
first pitch pop-up
ryan zimmerman letting josh harrison
know he's got it and this one into the
seventh
well he's just carving up the yankees
right now
that's drag out number 13. he's retired
12 in a row
swing and a miss on 95 away
10th time he has struck out 14 or more
is there any pitcher in baseball with
more mound presence
than max
scherzer
3-1
and frazier works a walk that's the
first walk issued
by max scherzer
and he popped him up
harrison backpedaling
wants soda well done he's going to take
charge let his second baseman know he
was there and a very important first out
he's at 109
tying his season most
and max is going to accept the decision
of his skipper what a day
seven and a third
one walk
a yankee stadium opponent record 14
strikeouts
nice fastball low in the zone
harrison zimmerman to the ninth we go
quite a battle next urs are still in
line for the w
[Music]
3-1
he walked him wasn't even close
so lemayo leads off with a walk the time
runs on base
[Applause]
the 1-0
that one is looped to right field that
could drop in let's see if it does it
does
lamellae is up third he's going to stop
right there he had to hold up a bloop
single for judge and it's first and
third and one man out runners lead at
first and third with one out bottom of
the ninth
pitch is line to right field there's a
base hit to tie the game lemay who
scores judge goes to second it's a base
hit and an rbi for global torrez and the
yankees have tied the game at two
and on that breaking ball a soft liner
on a hop to harrison
so the save blown but bret hand
pretty amazing to get out of the rest of
the inning
fastball base head
stevenson coming around third bob henley
holds him
and a fantastic at bat for victor robles
down in the count 02. i think it's a
spot where you want turner to try to put
the ball in play here they're going to
bring the infield in
and turner gets the bat on the ball
lines out to judge
stevenson great speed coming home the
nats are on top in the 10. brad hand is
back on the mound face mike ford there
goes clint frazier at second base
and now when he hits through the left
side for base hit frazier rounds third
he's coming home he'll score a big hit
for ford in rbi single and the game is
tied at three judge at the plate first
and second nobody out 3-0 count way
outside didn't come close
and the yankees are 90 feet away from
winning this game as they load the bases
nobody out 1-2 coming to torres pitch
swung on a little dribbler toward third
the throw we made it home scoring is the
mayhew ball game over yankees win
yankees win